نشاه الدرعيه كعماره حديثه سابق لقيام
امريكا او لاكتشاف كولومبوس لامريكا حسب
كلام فيلبي صحيح فاذا يعني تاريخ عريق
تتكلم يعني الحكم السعودي او العمق
التاريخي انتروبولوجيا للحكم السعودي عمق
تاريخي قديم يمتد من سنه 850 للهجره اي
ليس حتى ليس ولاده سنه 1139
قلنا الامتداد الامتداد التاريخي
انتروبولوجيا في الجانب السياسي
حسب المصادر العلميه ذكرته سنه 850 للهجره
طيب اخر شيء دكتور داهمنا
بجمله وجيزه هل تعتقد انه تم الافاده من
الارشيف العثماني بشكل الكافي والى ماذا
تدعو يعني ما هي المبادرات التي يمكن
الافاده منها بالنسبه الى ما هو معروض
الان من الارشيف العثماني بنو الباحثين
حقائقهم واستنتاجاتهم
ونتائج دراساتهم ولكن انا اتوقع في
ظهور المزيد من الوثائق العثمانيه
والسجلات سوف تظهر حقائق جديده وسوف تندثر
حقائق الان نعتبرها مسلمات وخاصه في تاريخ
الجزيره العربيه مثل ما ظهرت وثيقه
ابراهيم بن موسى نعم مثل ما بينتنا قدم
وعراقه الحكم هذه الاسره في الدرعيه في
الدرعيه يعني وحتى في صور اعتقد
قلتوغرافيه كمان السلطان عبد الحميد لم
يكشف النقاب على النقاب